[Applaudissements]
Mami de grâce ne Mons pas sous la gorge
àupidon
sa propre
flèche tant d'amour l'ont
essayé qui de leur bonheur ont payé
ce ça
sacrilège j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
[Musique]
demander ta main ne gravons pas nos noms
au bas d'un
parchemin laissons le champ libre à
l'oiseau nous serons tous les deux
priseau
ni sur
Paro au diable les maîtresses que
qui attache les cœurs au queue des
casseroles j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne gravons pas nos noms
au bas d'un
parchemin Vénus fait vieille souvent
elle perd son latin devant là
l'che frie
h à aucun prix moi je ne veux effeuiller
dans le pote au feu
la
marguerite j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
deander ta main ne gravons pas nos noms
au bas d'un
parchemin on leur ôte bien des attraits
en dévoilant trop les secret de
[Musique]
Mus l'encre des billets d' PAL vit entre
les feuillets des
lreux de
cuisine j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta
main ne gravons pas nos noms au bas d'un
[Musique]
parchemin il peut sembler de tout repos
de mettre à l'ombre au fond d'un pot de
confitu
hureux la jolie pomme
défendue mais elle est cuite elle a
perdu son goût
nature j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te
demander ta main ne gravons pas nous nom
au bas d'un
parchemin le servante n'ai pas besoin et
du ménage et de ses soins
je te
dispense qu'un éternel fiancé à la dame
de mes
pensées toujours je
pense j'ai l'honneur de ne pas te de
demander ta main ne gravons pas nos noms
au bas d'un
[Musique]
parchemin